[Musica]
siamo su the beast inside che vuol dire
la bestia dentro per farvi una
traduzione così facciamo anche un po di
inglese oggi no chi è un gioco horror
bello pesante che è uscito adesso
praticamente da pochissimo avevo giocato
la demo circa un annetto fa non so se lo
ricordate lo ricordo io io me lo ricordo
benissimo purtroppo oh che bello
già me la ricordo vi ricordate raga non
sono annetto fa che l'ho fatto è
bellissimo ma home sweet home casa dolce
casa o raitre e devo portare le scatole
dentro tutto io devo fare in questa vita
tutto io
hyper per entrare in soffitta va bene ho
messo il cosa posso entrare in soffitta
devo portare nelle scatole in soffitta
otranto le soffitte non l'ho mai capite
quelle che fanno così cioè non ho non
sono un esperto di soffitte non potevate
mettere una scala normale a questo punto
non lo so diamo di sopra non si può
andare di sopra c'è la chiave roventi
serve eccola very good
nel viaggio in macchina ovviamente non è
manco caduta e rimasta infilata va bene
ce ne andiamo al piano di sopra ragazzi
e questo il modo giusto di passare primo
giorno in casa dentro lattico senza mia
moglie ciao
tra l'altro i vecchi proprietari di casa
vedo che ha lasciato praticamente tutto
così
c'è tutto compreso nell'acquisto molto
bene cosa facciamo
ho davanti in giro così il macinino di
mia nonna aveva anche lei citri tavole
tic tac e io qua dentro per fare gli
spetti find painting di ethic devo
trovare il quadro nell'attico madonna
quante porte in un attico gigante devo
trovare il quadro nell'artico quale
quadro a paint sarebbe la pittura non
quadro che pirla non sono bravo in
inglese sorry
e lui non è bravo a fermare gli oggetti
qualcosa di nascosto sotto la tegola
sarà coronarico
invece serve al piede di porco tra
l'altro ragazzi noto che la casa è molto
bella perché non solo c'è la casa che è
una casa della madonna ma c'è anche
delle viuzze che vanno in fondo alla
foresta con la casa dei sette nani
meraviglioso dovrei raggiungere un
capanno degli attrezzi io non starei mai
in una casa con un'altalena rodotà prova
vento il satana è stato satan amico mio
va bene e devo trovare un piede di porco
perché se non riesco ad aprire le cose
con la tegola prova che non c'è io so
che nelle case americane c'è sempre un
capanno per gli attrezzi qua non lo vedo
quindi però c'è un fiume
cioè quanto vorrei vivere in una casa
così ragazzi down a mille e mille sono
sicuro tranne la notte la notte 0 2 ore
a cercare il piede di porco ed era c'era
un'altra scala nell'attico io mi voglio
ammazzare ragazzi sono un osservatore
patetico sono patetico
come ho fatto a non vedere che c'era un
altro punto
bella questa shadow non ho visto st
scanu non c'era permesso scala ma porca
vacca
ma come facesse così stupido parco
demonio mettili tira iv e v a large o
che sono trovato un tesoro non le
ricordo che cos'è la sta roba però mi
ricordo che c'era un codice per aprirla
che era tipo o fede parte pro in meno in
europa nei box pare che sia fede
bree di una cagata ferite a distanza di
un anno se funziona mia me ne vado non
mi ricordo che c'è una scala di bianco
ma mi ricordo il codice per aprire la
scatola distanza di un anno io sono un
[ __ ] genio incompreso un anno è
passato un anno mi ricordo il codice io
me ne vado ragazzi cè un diario vediamo
proprio network proprietà di nicolas ha
messo a leggere ok ospite non invitato
siamo tornati nel 1800
quattro ragazzi non sto leggendo niente
perché tanto mi risparmiano nasce
leggere l'inglese kent quindi vado
avanti e siamo tornati indietro nel
tempo e lo successo qualcosa nel 1864
qualcosa che dovremmo scoprire la mia e
non c'è bisogno di leggere perché tanto
mi succederà quindi va bene insomma
aspetta posso prendere questo perché me
lo porto in giro che non vedo da house
no però ho trovato degli accendini
ottimo non lo so ma non mi interessa mi
sono pagato in mano c'è il cap senso e
anioni sopra sia aperta la finestra
boccino buona sapersi spetta intanto
facendo non accendo niente bello però
sorprenderebbero me lo porto a casa
la dondolando qualcosa li succedeva
qualcosa adesso non mi ricordo un corpo
e si è schiantato un corpo sulla
finestra youtube salve
buongiorno non avvenga qui no non se ne
vada di là chi diavolo è quello e non lo
voglio sapere
vivi del 1864 credi alle streghe non
rompere ma non è vero
mi scusi è proprietà privata questa ma
guardate se non devo scendere ad andare
a prendermi james carr io mi scusi ma
come si permette qua gli venga pena io
farei proprio così in una situazione del
genere che faccio veramente bene e sto
gioco il problema è che l'inizio l'avevo
già fatto nella demo quindi più o meno
sole cose che succede sapevo solo questo
adesso non mi riconobbe niente in realtà
mi ricordo che un certo punto vado nel
seminterrato e blu storia
questo è il cappello di mio padre ha dei
dubbi i gusti per i capelli spaceman
ecco appunto piano sta parte o siamo
riusciti a pagare questa cosa sono
contento
ab shanghai previamente hanno trovato un
morto con tanti tagli e bruciature su
tutto il corpo cosa sta succedendo e
civiche e in più sto cercando di capire
cosa è successo a mio padre ho trovato
un cappelli sanguinato di mio padre e mi
dicono di andare nel seminterrato che io
nel seminterrato
ma non ci vado ma sa che non c'era prima
è una fattoria ma cos'è mai nuova non
c'è
quando ho comprato st kasami l'hanno
buttata giù questa è nuova e vecchia
nella casa gli quando sto comandando il
personaggio nuovo non c'era questa ma
salve e non sapevo che vivesse in casa
mia mi scusi mi dice dove ha preso il
pigiama faccio software
aiuti a quanto in gu
[Musica]
sono anni che gioca gli horror e non mi
abituerò mai a questa cosa comunque a
salve benissimo il diario è stato
aggiornato non lo voglio leggere andiamo
via
si può chiudere la finestra per favore
che già la prima non facciamo ascoltare
la gente di fuori per cortesia devo
andare nel basement il basement st 18
andiamo 18 mi aspetto tutte le candele
quasi tutte tu stai fermo che già ci
manca solo ci manca solo che ti muovi
pure dubbio che è successo è svenuta una
serie a no ragazzi ho visti ti prego ve
lo chiedo per cortesia non mi fate
girare le balle
vi prego qual è il proprio perché un
orco demonio porco morto perché nel 1800
la gente moriva di infarto per questo
mamma mia ragazzi mamma mia oh cioè
sicuro un accendino che non voleva
accendere la mannaia the lying filho do
sai dove tu a busto lanciarlo posso
usare ovviamente non come oggetto
difensivo ci mancherebbe altro
però contro i piatti si peccato avrei
voluto vedere con la fazione mille pezzi
sfruttiamo la sta roba bay quadri
complimenti
sfruttiamo sta roba qua laddove viene
tutto questo sangue
non lo so però c'è l'aspetto basement
quindi altri nel basement
molto bene io non mi ricordo niente
ragazza se non da fare però mi ricordo
che ciambetti c'è qualcuno qui dentro
come sono contento io tra l'altro sta
roba vela sto portando indietro nella
tasca se vedi che qualcuno e nel
basement c'è del sangue nel basement sta
bussando la porta tu la tua avventura
apri tu ti ammazzi quello dovresti fare
guarda che dato non c'è nessuno mai è lo
sapevo come sempre si stesse cosa non è
una guida in via non è una coda di due
ace del dolore non è una budai di ace
del sangue per terra pirla cioè quale
quale dovrebbe essere una salve questo è
un oro al fatto bene comunque questo
possiamo dirlo sono io che sono fatto
male non sono proprio i topi il mio
problema in questo momento però posso
usare team ungheri mandel di win skyrim
usa il grimaldello non usiamo il grande
dovevo trovare gli out of the rain man
va bene allora con telonio molto è me
l'hanno piazzata pensi non mi sono
appena disintegrato il ginocchio destro
ragazzi non so se vi interessa saperlo
quindi io sono in casa suo investigando
in casa di mio padre
io vorrei capire mio padre che i gusti
cia nell'arredamento però quella una
triste non me ne frega niente papa va
benissimo
va benissimo mi piace come gli succedono
le cose lui non è felice o mio dio dice
robe tipo facebook ma cosa ti amo lo è
ma cosa sarà mai non si apre perché ci
sono i tentacoli dell'outlander man
quindi dovremmo trovare allende celo
celo le forbici esatto ecc e sangue
ce l'ho fatta
avevo già l'oggetto giusto potrei anche
usarlo contro i nemici non si sa mai per
caso anche salvarti la vita
pensate ok d'acqua in avanti non ho
fatto niente ragazzi alla demo finiva lì
quindi vediamo se madonna
mamma mia ragazzi che gioco brutto ma
basta fatti una vita ti spieghi nella
prima donna se non ti prendo schiaffi in
faccia guarda ma se n'è andato proprio
avrei dovuto fissarlo mentre salivo le
scale brutta cosa fissare un altro punto
che vado adesso ho tratto un altra
chiave chiave misteriosa alla chiave
misteriosa prende altre basement avrei
basement
sentite
perché perché gli altri chi erano io io
non mi piace che il pieno di gente in
casa e lui dice ma chi sei tu come hai
fatto ad entrare o mio dio
poi arriva questa nuova e via perché gli
altri erano amichevoli no questo stava
leggendo il diario il diario finisce
ovviamente liberi che in tutto questo li
stava scrivendo però hagens la nostra
parte
vado a far vedere diario a mia moglie
moglie madre rai che lui hanno trovato
non dire che c'è un demonio mentre di
giri mi sono pagato in mano meno male
non controlla la scatola dei fusibili
nel basement così vediamo anche che cosa
c'era dietro quella misteriosissima
porta alla fine scatole di madonna di
dio è brutto scegli accendi madonna
potresti accendere la luce da qualche
parte non si può perché mi mancano
classe è un cavallo sei tranquillo non è
previsto un cavallone basement manca un
fusibile va bene devo andare nel sud
sarebbe qualcosa di legno che sta de
fori delle case americane quello lo chef
cassetta degli attrezzi vibo
eccoli cos'è sta roba
quantum local heiser localizza le tracce
quantiche ma boh mi piace che vede le
cose quel non può quindi sembra di
guardare veramente un horror show
primati io sto guardando un film horror
e non sto giocando
comunque il mio analizzatore quantico ho
preso da amazon ma dai che figata
bellissimo quindi io sto andando nella
direzione giusta per cercare la persona
che prima mi ha chiuso la porta pratica
un s ok vediamo stessa roba poi
incredibile cioè se invece era una
persona qui che si è avvicinato e ha
lasciato i vestiti
lì per terra e questo quando lo fa
vedere il mio quanto malana analyzer
ragazzi lo voglio anch'io non sono come
si trovano non esisteva lo voglio
maledizione quantum analyzer nella mia
vita non lo cerco su amazon fermi tutti
esiste non è tanto portatile lo devi
attaccare alle cose però carino quantum
risonanza quantic analyzer c'è anche
l'attacco del microfono bellissimo
iscrivetevi al canale schiacciate il
tasto mi piace e noi come sempre ci
rivediamo a un prossimo video
ricordatevi quantum analyzer se mi
volete portare i raduni io li accetto
beh ragazzi
[Musica]